conspiracy theories a global phenomenon
some may people deny the existence of
the new coronavirus
while believing that vaccination is
about the implementation of
brain chips others incite voters who
just lost an election to assault
democratic institutions
like those trump supporters storming the
u.s capitol to stop
congress clear the way for a joe biden
presidency
today's events did not happen
spontaneously
the president who promoted conspiracy
theories that motivated these thugs
the president who exhorted them to come
to our nation's capital
egg them on
he hardly ever discourages violence
and more often encourages it are people
who believe in conspiracy theory is just
gullible
or is there more to it and how worried
should we be
[Music]
welcome to our curvy 19 special i'm
monica jones in berlin a city that
seen its fair share of protests by
conspiracy theory followers we even
had a group storming the steps to the
german parliament a few months ago
not quite as dramatic as in washington
but shocking enough
so who are these people and what drives
them
some of them wear foil hats to protect
themselves against radiation or ward off
other evil spirits
often considered harmless conspiracy
theorists they have now come to the
notice of germany's domestic
intelligence agency
the office for the protection of the
constitution
the crisis around the coronavirus is a
perfect fit
some argue that it doesn't exist at all
others that it was invented by
politicians to control us
as a spectrum the spectrum ranges from
mainstream society to people with
esoteric views
there's nothing illegal about that but
they are now protesting alongside
right-wing populists
who for their part are trying to exploit
and conspiracy theorists point to
perceived similarities with 1933
when adolf hitler seized power in
germany and the fascist dictatorship
began
some people demonstrating against the
coronavirus measures have compared
themselves
to the jewish victims of the holocaust
but we are here for alameda what we're
seeing here is the trivialization
and even denial of the holocaust of
course that's absolutely unacceptable
it's not just anti-semitic it's a
criminal offence
one challenge facing investigators is
the lack of organized
structures among conspiracy theorists
there are branches of the american q
anon movement in germany
but there's no reliable information
about how many people belong to the hard
core of conspiracy theorists here
however
surveys suggest that one in three people
believes that there is a grain of truth
in their elaborate stories
for more let's bring in pierre lamberty
a psychologist who's dedicated uh a lot
of time
on analyzing the root causes and the
nature of conspiracy theories good to
have you with us
and of course we have to start with uh
with what's happened in washington
i mean this uh this people storming
the capital there is this uh
conspiracy theory at its worst
um yeah that's actually one of the
consequences
of conspiracy beliefs we showed that in
our research that people who believe in
conspiracies
are not only more likely to use violent
but also more likely to use
non-democratic
approaches to fulfill their goals so
actually what
experts were warning the whole time now
happened
and i'm not completely surprised because
trump was trying to mobilize the people
for
years and yeah destabilizing democracy
it's actually just a result of this
campaigns
is this how worrying is this um because
obviously we've seen
a lot of protest movements over here as
well
anti-coronavirus measures protests
those theories that are behind a lot of
these protests they're not new
but the followers of the theories are
certainly more vocal and visible now
attracting a lot of media coverage so
how big a phenomenon is it i would say
that before kuna it was like
one third of the population in germany
who believed more or less
in conspiracies like their secret powers
who were ruling
everything or that hiv was made up this
kind of stuff
since the pandemic you can assume that
there's an
increase but we don't know that yet for
sure
because we have no comparison before
and after the pandemic but if you look
at the social media channels you see
a huge increase on platforms like
telegram you see that they are
mobilizing more on the streets so
i don't know if there are more but yeah
it's more relevant for them right now
how dangerous is it to us as individuals
because we look at it from the outside
and say what are these people doing why
are they why do they believe that
how susceptible are we uh when it comes
to falling for conspiracy theories
when you look at disinformation wrong
claims we all believed in things that
are not true
that happens easily so i for myself
believed
for a long time that you eat eight
spiders in a lifetime
that's not true that's a fake news that
some journalists made up years ago when
the internet was
newer when it comes to conspiracies i
think also
many people actually believe
a little bit in them and what we do in
psychology is we measure the conspiracy
mentality that means the general
tendency to believe and conspiracy or
not and most people are on the scale in
the middle that means they believe a
little bit in it
and there are only a few who completely
refused it and don't have that mindset
and it's also the question if this is
better because people who have no
conspiracy mindset
i'd also say police they are doing
everything right
whatever they do i think they're amazing
and this is also not a critical
perspective on society so being in the
middle is actually not the worst thing
is this actually a a typical western
phenomenon
that we're talking about conspiracy
theories so conspiracy theories exist or
the belief in it access
all over the world psychologists um
yeah even think at least some of them
that it has an evolutionary basis so
that there is uh it's rooted in our
systems
um there's one bigger study that was
conducted in the summer and that looked
at
conspiracy beliefs in seven different
countries um
and for example in india 72 percent of
the
people believed that coronavirus is
actually a chinese bio weapon
that's a huge amount of people and
in the us for example it was 32 which is
still
every third person that believes that
kind of things
and when you look at narratives like
that 5g
this new phone network standard
is responsible for the corona virus in
germany you have seven percent who
believe that but in
jordan for example it's also one third
of the population and this is linked to
following the measures less like wearing
no face mask
or being not likely to get a vaccine
or also using violence so it is linked
to behavior
in the pandemic and it hinders us to
manage the pandemic
and i think it's important to have a
look at this on an early stage
and have concepts how to deal with that
because
these vaccine centers are likely to be
attacked
not maybe physically but that people go
there and
interrupt people in their work and yeah
we need concepts how to deal with that
and how to prepare the employees there
we've just entered the second year of
the pandemic will we see
even worse protests will conspiracy
theories thrive even more
i think it also depends on how um the
government reacts
so if a certain kind of protests are not
allowed
then they won't happen but they look of
course for other wastes like
giving flyers and stuff like that so
they try to react to the yeah
restrictions that they have but
of course the demonstration has another
powerful impact you see the pictures
they look
very motivating for the scene so it
depends on directions of the government
but i think especially the topic of
vaccination
was always since vaccinations were
invented part of conspiracy theories
and therefore that's crucial to really
sit down
and have strategies how to deal with
that
worldwide not only in germany because
there will be probably attacks
and there were already attacks against
scientific institutions also in germany
very worrying outlook there pia lamberty
psychology is an expert on conspiracy
theories thank you so much
you're welcome bye right time for your
questions now
over to our science correspondent derek
williams
why do children have so few symptoms of
covid19
and have fewer side effects
one of the things that's puzzled
researchers since the beginning of the
pandemic has been the effect
that the disease has on kids they just
don't seem to get it as often as adults
do and when they do
it only rarely turns severe why not
well experts now think that various
factors could be playing roles
the first involves differences in immune
response in children
and adults that hypothesis focuses
on the emergency system that responds to
an exposure fast
called the innate immune system its
proponents say that because
the innate response is still largely
untrained in young children it might
often react
more powerfully and quickly to infection
with sars cove too than it would in an
adult
wiping out the virus before it has time
to gain a foothold
another train of thought says that
what's called a cross-reactivity
might be playing a role anyone who has
kids
is familiar with the seemingly
never-ending
series of sniffles that they bring home
from daycare and from school
by some estimates they have cold
symptoms three to four times
more often than adults do on average
that means that a child's blood stream
is this kind of
seething boiling cauldron of antibodies
against the coronaviruses
that cause common colds and the theory
is
that some of those antibodies might also
have
a cross-reactive protective effect
that they might also be able to to latch
onto
and disable source cove ii there are
more explanations out there for
why kids have fewer symptoms with
covid19 but
but those two are the most common